[Music]  for all the mi fans it really is a  culmination of every film every mission  is led to this one suit up no one had  ever jumped out on film at this altitude  we were told that it's impossible you  use a scalpel I prefer a hammer  everything we do is real there's huge  stakes put my foot up literally for a  split second I knew this is the tape  [Music]  I was inches away from the sides and  clips we just pulled out all stops  [Applause]  and begin to say why you guys enjoy this  so much shoot  when the hell is he doing for the best  not some hook  you're just full of surprises possible  fallout on digital November 28th and on  blu-ray December 4th